si de hecho comenzamos también
mencionando que anoche boto la cámara de
representantes esta resolución que le
pedía al vicepresidente mike pence
precisamente eso que invocará el
artículo 25 una resolución sobre todo
simbólica porque no era vinculante y
sobre la cual minutos antes de que se
votara el vicepresidente mike pence
había escrito esta carta en la que decía
que no era para el interés del país y no
era consistente con la constitución
aprobar
precisamente esta resolución que
invocaba el artículo 25 queda claro
entonces que mike pence no pues seguirá
apoyando esta iniciativa de parte de la
cámara de representantes y de los
demócratas de querer pues que salga del
poder en ocho días que le quedan a su
administración esto a pesar de que el
mitch mcconnell y otros cinco
republicanos de andy ya han dicho que
pues apoyarán la iniciativa que tienen
hoy los demócratas de aprobar el primer
artículo del imperio en sería la segunda
vez que los demócratas
pasen por el proceso de impeachment el
presidente de trump sin embargo
obviamente este proceso tiene bastantes
dificultades de ser aprobado por el
senado de mayoría republicana bueno
precisamente y rápidamente le pido
cristo vale que nos cuente para los
televidentes cómo iría este proceso en
la cámara y cómo sería recibido en el
senado
si sería recibido como dicen analistas
por una mayoría republicana en total
serían 17 republicanos más o menos que
tendrían que pues salirse de las líneas
de su partido y apoyar esta iniciativa
para que tengan los dos tercios
necesarios para poder aprobar en el
senado el impeachment del presidente
algo que lleva muchos debates lleva
mucho tiempo y que no alcanzaría en
estos ocho días que quedan para que el
presidente camps sea destituido de su
cargo como dice mike pence en su carta
donde niega y rechaza el artículo 25 le
pide a los demócratas de la cámara
representante que dejen los juegos
políticos que dejen de tratar de dividir
al país que dejen de hacer esto más
inflamable y pide unión en ese en esa
carta del vicepresidente mike pence a
los demócratas de la cámara de
representantes que se unan para lograr
una transición pacífica y para que yo
vaya pueda empezar bien su gobierno